[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much, Clive.
And thanks very much
everyone for coming out
on this rather
warm evening, which
is really impressive for
someone even from Australia.
So synthetic intelligence.
So what is intelligence?
It's something that is quite
subtle and very difficult
to put your finger on.
The adjective synthetic
refers to something
that is manmade, that is a
replica of something that
occurs in nature.
So we often use
the word synthetic
when we're talking about
synthetic fabrics, for example,
or perhaps synthetic molecules,
like insulin for example.
So synthetic intelligence
gives the connotation
that it's intelligence that
we're making ourselves.
But how does it differ from
artificial intelligence?
You're all probably
quite familiar
with artificial intelligence
even though you might not fully
understand it yourselves.
So my talk this
evening is actually
going to be about this new thing
called synthetic intelligence
that is actually quite different
from artificial intelligence.
And I'm going to tell you
a little bit about how
it differs, and
why it's important,
and how it might bring us
even closer to understanding
real human intelligence.
I've divided my talk very
roughly into three parts.
The first part of
my talk I wanted
to put things into
context and just give you
a really broad overview of what
artificial intelligence is.
And I'm going to do that because
I want to explain to you why
artificial intelligence is
artificial, how it differs
from real human intelligence.
And then I'm going to tell you
a little bit about some cutting
edge research that
involves actually making
manmade devices that
replicate the human brain,
a synthetic brain, and
how we can try and emulate
thinking processes from these
devices that we've made.
In the last part
of my talk, which
is going to be
the shortest part,
I'm just going to wrap up a
little bit with some ideas,
some viewpoints of my own.
And, of course, I'll
be looking forward
to hearing your comments
and questions afterwards.
Before that, as
Clive mentioned, he's
also going to have a bit
of a discussion with me
around this topic as well.
So let's get started.
So all of you by now have heard
of artificial intelligence.
In fact, the world
seems to be infatuated
with artificial intelligence.
It's been applied to
everything from social media
to constructing Ikea furniture.
But as I indicated, artificial
intelligence is artificial.
But why is it so successful?
How does it work to
make it so successful?
Well, all it is, it's
something that takes some data,
puts it into an algorithm,
and the output of that
is predictions.
Now an algorithm is nothing but
some mathematics and some code.
And there are different types
of programming languages
that you can use to
code up the mathematics.
The mathematics basically
just describes different ways
to analyse the data.
And the different ways of
analysing the data depends
on the different types of
data that you're interested.
It might be social media data
or it might be some other kind
of recognition data like if you
want to recognise car number
plates for example.
Now the outputs of this
combination of data
and algorithms is predictions.
Importantly, these are
statistical predictions.
So that means that they have
some inherent uncertainties
that depend on the amount of
data that's available to be
processed and analysed.
The reason why
artificial intelligence
is called artificial
intelligence
is because prediction
itself is something
that the human brain
does really, really well.
It's actually a hallmark
of intelligence.
And so hence the adjective here
of artificial intelligence.
The artificial comes in also
because essentially what this
is doing is just brute force
analysing lots and lots
of data.
But in addition to the
quantity of data that's
required for artificial
intelligence,
it's also the quality of
the data that matters.
If you have insufficient amounts
of data or poor quality data,
then the predictions that
that AI machine makes
becomes less reliable.
So for example, if you have
a whole bunch of data where,
for example, you do want to
recognise patterns on licence
plate numbers, for example, if
you throw in some random data
into the mix, your predictions
will actually then result
in larger and larger
uncertainties,
becoming less reliable.
So both quality and
quantity of the data
are hugely important in
artificial intelligence.
Now the algorithm in artificial
intelligence is also important.
And probably the
most exciting types
of algorithms that
are now used in AI
are algorithms referred
to as neural networks.
And they're called
neural networks
because they do, in some ways,
resemble the human brain,
at least in the way it operates.
So they are loosely
based on the human brain
in the following way.
The algorithms use
something called networks
to connect different bits
of information together.
And they also iterate
through the data
at varying degrees of levels.
And these varying degrees
of levels also means that
sometimes these neural networks
are also referred to as deep
learning, the deep indicating
how many levels of iterations
you go through to
analyse the data.
Now neural network AI
algorithms are most commonly
used for pattern recognition.
And again, this rings back
to the intelligence part
of artificial intelligence,
because the human brain is
actually really, really good
at recognising patterns.
You think about when you're
out on the streets of London,
for example.
Out of all those people,
if a friend of yours was
on the other side of the street,
you'd be able to recognise them
instantly.
So the brain does
this remarkably well.
And these neural
network algorithms
do this remarkably
well as well provided
that there's good quality data
and a large quantity of it.
And of course, we're
in the 21st century.
We have the internet.
So we actually now do have
really large quantities of data
available at our fingertips.
And the quality is actually
very, very good as well.
And this is the reason why
neural network algorithms
were first invented in the
1970s but are only now enjoying
this Renaissance because we have
so much data available to us.
Now probably the
most famous example
of the application of neural
network algorithms in AI
was IBM's DeepMind AI which
beat the chess grandmaster
Garry Kasparov in 1997.
And Garry Kasparov
has actually written
a book recently about this.
And he's actually a
very strong proponent
of AI himself despite
the fact that he
was beaten by a machine.
Another popular example
is Google's DeepMind AI,
which was designed specifically
for playing the Chinese game
AlphaGo.
And a very recent
development in AlphaGo
was AlphaGo Zero, which
is a further development
on the original AI
algorithm developed
by Google that now
doesn't need to play
against any other human being.
AlphaGo Zero actually
taught itself
by playing against
itself to optimise how
it plays this particular game.
So things are developing
at a pretty rapid pace.
And it's very impressive.
However, both
those two examples,
playing chess and
playing AlphaGo,
represent the fact that
those applications of AI
demonstrate that
AI is really still
very limited to specific tasks.
And so there's a big push on
at the moment for developing
and extending AI further to try
and realise artificial general
intelligence.
So in other words, how
can we get these AIs
to actually be successful
at broader ranges of data,
not just data that
is relevant to chess
or relevant to playing AlphaGo
but relevant for broader
applications.
This is really important because
the way the human brain works
is through general intelligence.
We have the ability
to triage and philtre
very broad bandwidth
data and information
that we are constantly
taking in all the time
as you are all doing right now.
We're doing this on the fly in
real time with minimal effort.
Our brains are doing
this over and over again.
We don't need some other
entity to import data
into us to preprogram us.
And we can actually do a
broad range of general tasks.
So whether AI as it
exists at the moment
can actually achieve that
is really a major research
direction for many
research groups
but also for some of these
major tech companies like IBM,
which just last month
actually demonstrated
an example of moving towards
artificial general intelligence
with their Project
Debater particular AI.
Now the Project Debater
AI developed by IBM
was actually designed
so that it could engage
in debate with human beings.
It was incredibly impressive,
because it really started
to get closer to reason.
You know, it was
presented with two topics.
And it was engaging
with two human beings.
And it was required to present
a viewpoint, present a rebuttal,
and also to do a wrap up in
the standard debate format.
However, it's not true general
artificial intelligence,
because it still needed
to be preprogrammed.
It needed to know what
those two topics were.
Data needed to be input into
the system related to those two
topics.
And the right algorithms needed
to be put into place in order
to be able to achieve that.
So there's still a way
to go towards that.
So what I'm actually presenting
tonight is the question,
is there a different approach
to general intelligence--
emulating general intelligence,
an approach that's
different from the
software based AI approach.
So that's what I'm putting
to you this evening.
Now, of course, we have
actually seen some examples
of what I'm referring to
as a synthetic intelligence
approach to understanding and
emulating general intelligence
through movies such as
Ex Machina for example,
and the TV series
Humans, which I gather
is popular here in the UK.
These examples are,
of course, fictional.
And we've got a long
way to go to try and get
in close to this.
But they do present some
interesting ideas that perhaps
are not too far away from
the distant future in terms
of realising synthetic
intelligence.
And they really do show that
the most important aspect
of the human brain,
and how it thinks,
and how it demonstrates
intelligence
is by being interactive
with its environment--
as I mentioned before, gathering
information, being exposed
to information, processing
that information in real time.
And, most importantly, the human
brain and human intelligence
is resilient against
random things happening.
And this is probably the
most important limitation
of AI software based approaches
to general intelligence,
the fact that they're so
reliant on curated data
and large quantities of
data whereas the human brain
and human intelligence that
results from processes that
are happening in the
human brain can actually
deal with random things
being thrown at it.
We deal with that
remarkably well.
So our brains actually
have this enormous capacity
to be adaptive and resilient
against any types of data.
So that's the challenge
that we really
face with trying to emulate
general intelligence.
And this is why it's actually
valuable and important
that we come up with alternate
approaches to the software
based AI approach.
So I'm asking the
question this evening,
can we make a physical
brain-like device
with intelligence?
So in other words, I'm
asking the question,
can we view intelligence
as a physical phenomenon?
So in other words,
something that
can be described in terms
of physical processes.
If we can describe it in
terms of physical processes,
then we can actually build
a device that replicates
those physical processes.
In other words, we can actually
build a synthetic brain that's
a replica of the human brain.
So importantly, this is not
just about making a robot.
So robots as we know them today
are actually still controlled
by computational software.
They need to be preprogrammed.
So what I'm talking about is
taking a machine, or a device,
or something and putting
it inside a synthetic brain
so that it can then engage and
interact with its environment
and learn in the same way
that human brains learn.
So how do we do this?
What are the first steps?
Well, the human brain is
made up of brain cells
which are called neurons.
But these neurons are
also compartmentalised
into different
regions of the brain.
And these different
regions of the brain
also have different
functionalities.
Now importantly, the individual
neurons are connected together.
And the different
compartments of the brain
are also connected together.
So the whole brain is kind
of like this really complex
network.
And there are different
levels of the network
that is the brain.
So this is where
we need to start.
Two aspects.
One is we need to be
able to understand
how the brain functions at
the individual neuron level
and how those individual neurons
are connected together and also
then how they form these
compartments which are also
connected together.
And the second thing
is, moving away
from individual
neurons themselves,
we also then need
to understand what
happens on the global scale.
And this is quite
interesting, because,
at the individual
neurons scale, what
happens is that
neurons come together
and they communicate together.
We know that's an important
aspect of how the brain works.
But when we take
the brain globally,
and we consider the really
complex networks that
form between neurons and between
different regions of the brain,
there's something else
interesting that happens.
Those interactions
between neurons
and between different
parts of the brain
actually result in
emergent properties.
And that's really important.
What that means is that
the whole is greater
than the sum of its parts.
And we see a lot of this type
of behaviour in other complex
systems.
So in the brain,
it's really important
to be able to try and
replicate the complexity
of the network that
exists in the brain
in any kind of
synthetic brain that we
are attempting to recreate.
Now going back to
the individual neuron
level, what happens with
the neurons in the brain
is that they're all
connected to each other.
And when they get stimulated
by electrical stimuli,
they start sending
signals to each other.
And the signals
that get transmitted
through the neurons, which
are connected with each other,
is the way in which
signal transmission
occurs through the brain.
So it's communication
between neurons.
So what I'm going
to show you now
is a YouTube video
that synapses.
Synapses, basically, are the
way in which individual neurons
communicate with each other.
And could you play that
movie for me please?
Thank you.
So this YouTube video shows how
sensory input into the brain
becomes visually or through
smelling things and touching
things and so on result
in electrical signals
in the brain.
And these electrical
signals then
propagate through the neurons.
And the neurons
have these branches
that stretch out and
almost touch each other.
So you can see that kind of
treelike branching structure
between the neurons.
And those treelike structures--
branching structures
are important, because
at the end of them,
you can see that one end of
one of the neurons almost
touches another neuron.
And the gap that forms
between those two neurons--
you can see tiny
little molecules
which are called
neurotransmitter molecules.
And they actually travel
from one neuron to another.
So those neurotransmitter
molecules
represent the way
in which signals get
transmitted through neurons.
Now the brain has approximately
100 billion neurons in it.
But it has 1,000
trillion synapses.
And that's because
each of those neurons
can have multiple synaptic
connections with other neurons.
So the first step in
trying to design and build
a synthetic brain is
actually to try and start
with the neurons and
the synaptic connections
between the neurons.
Can we actually start with
that and build those first?
Well, of course,
the answer is yes.
And there's already
a lot of research
being done on that right now.
And I just saw the
slide that I wanted.
That one.
Thank you.
So the first step is, can
we build synthetic synapses?
These are the ways in
which two neurons can
communicate with each other.
And in the real
neuron case, they
communicate with each other
through these neurotransmitter
molecules.
So can we build a device that
replicates these synapses?
So there's a lot
of research being
done in this around the
world and with some really
remarkable and
impressive results
a lot of the efforts in this are
focusing on using semiconductor
electronic device components.
And the reason for this
is, if you remember,
I mentioned that
the human brain,
once it receives sensory
input, that actually sends out
electrical signals
through the human brain.
And those electrical
signals are what
drives those
neurotransmitter molecules
from one neuron to the other.
So since this process is
driven by electrical signals,
then it makes sense to
start emulating this
with electronic devices.
So that's what a lot
of groups have done.
They've started with
known electronic devices
in trying to construct
these synthetic synapses,
and then sending electrical
signals through them
and seeing if they
can get something
that looks like the way
that real synapses work.
So there has been some
remarkable success in this,
but there are two
major drawbacks.
So one of them is that once you
start using electrical device
components-- and these
are just things like stuff
that you make integrated
circuits out of.
There's nothing new here.
But once you start
using them, you're
immediately
restricted to working
on a 2D, two dimensional
integrated circuit
board, which is nothing
like what the brain is.
The brain is a 3D structure.
Right.
But also, it turns out that
electrical device components
on a circuit board,
you can't really
manipulate them too much.
First of all, they have
to be very sparsely
and carefully arranged.
And that is completely unlike
what happens in the real brain.
So I've mentioned to you
already that the real brain has
some a 1,000 trillion synapses.
So these are incredibly
dense connections.
And we just cannot replicate
that with existing electronic
device components.
The second problem
with this approach
is that electronic device
components as they exist today
actually use quite
a lot of power.
So we're talking about
megawatts of power
whereas the human
brain uses milliwatts.
So that's a billion
times more power
that's used by these
electronic device components.
That's a real problem.
However, that
problem is starting
to be solved through
an approach known
as neuromorphic computing.
So the term neuromorphic
means brain-like.
And IBM has actually
developed a new type
of chip technology called
neuromorphic chips that has now
reduced the power
consumption of their chips
down to levels that are
comparable with the brain.
That's been a
remarkable achievement.
Their main objective
in doing this
was really to try and
reduce the power consumption
in computing and computing
processes, particularly
for AI applications.
But power consumption
is a real problem.
And it's something that I'll
come back to later on as well.
So they've been quite
successful in this.
But their neuromorphic
chip devices,
which work because
they've actually
been able to completely scrap
with the original so-called Von
Neumann type architectures
of computer chips
that were developed in the
1950s that we still use today.
So they completely scrapped
that and completely changed
the architecture of their
chips to achieve those really
low power consumption levels.
But the thing is their
chips are not synaptic like.
So they're not
synthetic synapses.
So this still doesn't
get us anywhere closer
to how we can start
building a synthetic brain.
But there is another
technology, which
is called the atomic
switch technology.
And it was only relatively
recently commercialised
by the electronics company NEC.
It's a Japanese
electronics company.
And this is a completely
new technology.
It's not based on
semiconductors.
They've really started
from scratch with this.
And it's called atomic switch
because it acts like a switch,
going from an off
stage to an on state.
It's able to make that
transition extremely rapidly
in milliseconds if not
shorter timescales.
So it's already quite attractive
for computing applications
where you're working with
binary zeros and ones.
But it's also called
brain-like atomic switch
because it turns out that the
way that these switches operate
is exactly the
same as a synapse.
You have two regions
with a gap in between.
And when you put an electrical
signal across there,
you drive ions from
one side to the other.
And that is exactly
the same as the way
in which neurotransmitters
transmit electrical signals
in neural synapses.
So this has been a really
exciting development.
And there are other
really attractive features
of this atomic switch
technology such
as they have very
low volatility, which
means they don't
need to be maintained
as often as existing
semiconductor device
technologies.
And they have extremely low
power consumption as well.
Again, similar to what
the brain uses as well.
And in fact, NEC's
first application
is to put these devices
on space satellites,
because then they don't
have to worry about them.
There's low maintenance,
low volatility, low power
consumption.
So this is really an
exciting new technology.
And it's a
technology, as I said,
that mimics the
way that synapses
work in the human brain.
However, as you'll see with
this particular device,
it still faces a
limitation in moving it
to the next stage of
building a synthetic brain,
because it turns out that the
individual synapses are still
quite limited in terms of
the way they can be arranged
and how many
connections can actually
be achieved out of them.
So at the moment,
it's very difficult
to achieve a high
density of connectedness
with these atomic switches.
That's something that
people are working on.
But at the moment
we're not there yet.
Now this is a
schematic illustration
of what a real network
of neurons looks like.
And I showed you that brief
video earlier as well.
You can see that it
looks quite messy.
The neurons occupy 3D space.
And as I mentioned
and I'm emphasising,
they really connect with each
other with a high degree.
So it's a complex network.
It's a highly connected network.
And this is what we're
trying to emulate
in building a synthetic brain.
An important aspect
of that complexity
in the structure of
the real human brain
is that it enables something
called synaptic plasticity.
What this means is that
it allows the brain
to continuously respond to
input data, and information,
and continuously reconfigure
all the synaptic connections
that it makes with
all the neurons.
This is happening all
the time in our brains.
And this synaptic plasticity
is what neuroscientists now
attribute to our capacity
to remember things
and to learn, in other
words, our intelligence.
So synaptic
plasticity is the key
to actually emulating
general intelligence
as we have it in our brains.
And the way to do this is by
emulating the complex network
structure of the human brain.
That complexity is
absolutely essential.
So are there any technologies
that can actually--
where we can actually start to
emulate that complex network
structure that we see
in the human brain?
Well of course, the answer
is yes, because otherwise I
wouldn't be here this evening.
So this is the best technology
that we have at the moment
today of something that
is really now starting
to resemble the
structure and also
the function of the human brain.
This is what I've called here
a neuromorphic nanotechnology.
So let me describe what it is
that you're looking at here.
First of all, it's
an image taken
with an electron microscope.
An electron microscope has
incredibly high resolution
and therefore it's
used quite often
to image nanotechnology
devices, which
is what this is an example of.
What you're looking at, all
those individual strings that
appear to have this
very messy structure,
they are actually nanowires,
so nanoscale wires.
In this case, they're made
out of primarily silver.
But they're about
maybe 100 nanometers
in width and much, much
longer in length, typically
microns in length.
These nanowires actually
have incredibly interesting
properties.
And these interesting
properties only
emerge because they have
this nanoscale structure.
Now what's of interest to us for
the neuromorphic application,
the brain-like application,
first of all is the structure.
And you can see immediately
how much more similar
this type of structure is
to a real neural network
compared to other structures
that are based on semiconductor
device technologies.
But secondly, in addition
to the network structure
that these nanowires
can produce,
it turns out that, because
they form this complex network,
they actually overlap
in many, many areas.
And the locations at
which the nanowires
overlap with each other when you
put an electrical stimulation
over the network,
they actually behave
in exactly the same way as
synapses do in the sense
that, where two wires
overlap, they form a junction.
There's a gap between them.
And when that
junction experiences
an electrical
stimulation, it actually
drives ions from one wire to the
other in exactly the same way
that neurotransmitters
are transmitted
across synaptic connections
between neurons.
This is incredibly exciting.
And the results that we have
today actually show that you
can put different types of
electrical stimulations across
these networks and get the
network to exhibit memory
behaviour.
You can also train the
network by applying
the same stimulation over
and over again and getting
the network to
replicate that signal.
So I'm going to show
an example of how
we can get this kind
of nanotechnology that
emulates the brain
to actually start
getting it to learn something.
So what I'm going to
show you now is a movie.
And you can see on
the left hand side
the number two that's
being flashed up there.
Each one of those little
squares on both sides
represents an area where
we have this neuromorphic
nanotechnology
synapses if you like.
And electrical stimulations
are being delivered
to mimic the shape of the digit
two and also the digit number
one.
The difference is
that the digit number
one is being delivered
by electrical stimuli
at a much, much faster rate
than the electrical stimuli that
are used to generate
the number two.
At the end of this, you
can see that the number one
is retained much more strongly.
There's a faint resemblance
of the number two behind it,
but it's the number one that
has this very strong retention
by this device.
That demonstrates to
us that we can actually
control the way that this
device remembers things
by simply controlling
the rate at which we're
delivering information.
So we can control
the repetition rate
and therefore control
how it remembers things.
This is crucially important,
because this is exactly the way
that we remember things.
When we want to remember
something important,
whether it's for an
exam or something else
that we're interested
in, we read or go
over something over
and over and over again
and we get memory from that.
And importantly
also, the human brain
exhibits two different types
of memory, short term memory
and long term memory.
And we can actually start
now to see those differences
in the formation of these
two types of memories
from this type of nanotechnology
neuromorphic device.
It's actually
incredibly exciting.
Now short term memory
and long term memory.
The neuroscientists
have pinned that down
to being attributable
to synaptic plasticity.
So again, it's this complex
network structure that this
device is able to produce that
allows it to display these
different behaviours of
memory that are now starting
to emulate the way that
the real human brain works.
So where are we going with this?
So let me just finish up
with some views of my own.
So in 2006, the
World Economic Forum
put forth their view that
the 21st century is now
witnessing what they've
called the fourth Industrial
Revolution.
And of course, we saw the
first Industrial Revolution
in the 18th century.
19th century, we saw
another revolution
from the introduction
of electricity.
And then, of
course, 20th century
is perhaps best well
known by the invention
of the transistor and hence
the subsequent electronics
and computer industry.
Well, the fourth
Industrial Revolution
is characterised by several
emerging breakthrough
technologies which
include AI, of course,
the internet of
things, nanotechnology,
and space technology.
Now the fourth
Industrial Revolution
is going to be characterised
not by just one of these things.
It's going to be characterised
by the convergence of all
of these and probably more
breakthrough technologies
that we are yet to see.
We're only at the beginning
of the 21st century.
Where does synthetic
intelligence fit into this?
So I've explained to you how
synthetic intelligence provides
an alternate approach to AI
software based approaches.
I've also shown you how
important nanotechnology
is to synthetic intelligence.
We really couldn't have realised
a synthetic intelligence device
without nanotechnology.
The internet of things
basically describes
how the world is
becoming increasingly
connected on the global scale.
And at the moment,
that's being driven by AI
and the requirements of AI.
But that's actually
unsustainable
because of the power
requirements of AI.
You think about how many times
a day you do a Google search
and then stop and think about
how much power that actually
consumes.
A typical Google
search consumes about--
I think it's about 1
kilojoules of power.
That corresponds to
turning on a light bulb
for about 15 seconds.
You think about how much
of that goes on every day.
Most of that power is required
to keep the servers going,
so to keep them cool
and to store the data.
That cannot keep going on
if we really are going to be
experiencing this
Industrial Revolution.
We need better ways to be
interconnected and cleverer
ways.
Space technology I
haven't touched on yet.
But in my view, space
technology is the killer app
for synthetic intelligence
for the following reason.
We are now seeing a real
push, a genuine real push
backed by money, for
colonisation of the moon
and also Mars.
And if we're going to
do this, we actually
need synthetic intelligence
devices, autonomous systems
with syntactic synthetic
brains in them,
to send them out
and actually prepare
the moon and, of course,
Mars for human colonisation.
For Mars it's
absolutely critical.
There is no way we can
actually send manned space
missions out to Mars first off.
We need to be able to
send machines out there.
And those machines need to
be able to think adaptively
with minimal human
interventions.
There are going to be
long periods of time
where we are not going
to be able to communicate
with those kind of devices.
So they really need to be
as autonomous as possible.
And in fact, NASA is now
preparing autonomous systems
with increasing levels of
autonomy for their next Mars
Rover mission for 2020.
So this is where I see
the real application
for synthetic intelligence, or
at least the most exciting one
in my mind.
But just to finish
up my presentation,
I wanted to leave
you with a quote
from the famous British
mathematician, computer
scientist, and
logician Alan Turing.
Thank you very
much for listening.
[APPLAUSE]